citizens of reject Nation we are here at the
witching hour midnight to check out the official
trailer for saw X or 10 whatever we're going
with these days we were out at a little reject
Summit with some of the other faces you might
know from around here so we were not able to
catch this in real time but we're here now Greg
how you feeling Greg is feeling um like that I
consumed some stuff and I'm here to tell you that
uh if I didn't tell you you wouldn't even notice
I couldn't tell myself no man we're good we're
good it was fun did you have fun I had such a
good time leave a like for having a good time
I need everyone to have a good time big saw
fans we're big soft fans we're some of the
biggest soft fans you might find we've been
here for the whole day John I'm trying to ask a
question do you know uh when this takes place I
do I know a couple small things they've really
revealed weirdly we'll listen to a video about
it like three days ago oh good it's not
weird I've been looking forward to it is
it that play button everyone be quiet yeah
leave a like and we'll be talking about it
obnoxiously too long we'll see who sticks around
everyone all of you if you stick around comment
foreign ER
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid there's
nothing else we can do there is one person who
might be able to help our program is a two-pronged
treatment wow Mexico City the results have been
stunning she saved my life it's like all gonna be
from John Kramer's perspective you're in very good
hands with us I guess so [Music] after that what
happens then your whole life happens then John
Kramer oh no according to these scans you're
the devil the tumor was never removed oh no
months at best I still have a
lot of work that needs to be done
[Music] [Applause]
oh my goodness wow this looks like an actual saw
film I know right like the old school saw films
hello it's time to play a game
yes it is you play the game in
between the one I have planned
for each of you is very real wow
fascinating
the only thing I have not provided
is you're anesthetic of course me
Billy you will want to remain alert yes oh no
it also looks like an independent movie of all the
men to cheat you picked John
Kramer please don't hesitate
all the poster trapped the glass
enzyme tank this will save your life
retribution it's a Reawakening yeah
there's a lot more emotion here than
I thought yeah [Applause] [Music]
dang whoa Got Back guys we did a
sketch called Greg saw years ago yeah
it shows you how big a saw fans we are it's a
crowning Jewel of our sketch history do we say
that it takes place between saw one and two uh
did we say yeah did we say it out loud I think
we just said that we knew when it took place
and then we didn't actually established this
takes place between saws one and two yes all
right well John you are a much bigger I've seen
everyone at least once and a few several times
okay yeah is one of those saw six uh actually
no I've only seen it once but I really liked
it saw six is one of the better ones and this
is the director of Saw six which makes a lot of
sense yeah because this looked very surprisingly
emotional yeah that threw me for a loop like
visually it looks exactly like the soft it
doesn't because it started going down a direction
of where like we're trying to get Slicker yeah
we're trying to get cooler we're trying to rise
above the scuzzy music video hyper editing do
exactly that but it feels genuine in its approach
but this would this would still be the first time
that it is truly from like we're we're watching
this from John Kramer as if he is the protagonist
of the story yeah we've had flashbacks like that
and we've had obviously saw films where he's like
The prominent story but yeah this one apparently
he is like sort of the lead as well as the
enigmatic villain yeah because this surprisingly
leaned more on story and less on the Torture Games
and like look at the different devices we're gonna
have because a lot of the devices look pretty
generic if you ask me shop but sure it's about the
entire context rather than just yeah but I kind of
like that the reason why is because you know that
feeling when you watch a prequel and it feels like
way more updated yeah and like where was all
this [__] in the one that wasn't the prequel
it was all that craziness because it's still a
fairly early stage for John Kramer yeah before
he started was it was saw two of let me get a
bunch of let me get a whole how do I rent a house
let's take one room let's do every room and
they're all related to each other yeah so
having it be a little bit more Back to Basics
works for the story yeah yeah and in a way
where like I respected what they wanted to do with
Jigsaw uh that installment but that even has that
uh quality where it is like this is in the past
technically or some of it is or it's inspired by
like a direct game from the past that does seem
much crazier than a lot of stuff we've seen up
until now and for this being between one and two
this still feels like that DIY charm and in some
of those flashbacks that you get and I think it is
six like some of those old traps are like really
janky and it's just like oh he just rigged a
bunch of knives together or like a bike chain
and some drills or something and so yeah Alex
was the one where he wasn't getting he didn't
get the cancer treatment right yeah that was the
one okay six is the one where they're going after
like all the different people in this insurance
insurance companies yeah yeah I remember that
yeah and so yeah this one you know I guess will
be about some kind of corrupt Medical Institute
praying on the you know the needy and the weak
but uh but it also had more of a Macabre humor
yeah certainly I mean it'll be interesting humor
yeah to see how that's grown because like you know
Saw movies can be kind of Bleak but I feel like
right now it has to be a little self-aware very
serious yeah I I rarely say a a saw trip I mean
we might have said about previous saw trailers
um but this particular one managed to
look and feel like the original saw films
but still also managed to feel fun
yeah whereas the other ones take uh
jigsaw was was the one before spiral right
yeah jigsaw that that like looked fun
if it didn't look necessarily like saw sure it's
again that polished thing of like it's saw but for
like a slightly new generation and everything's
like a little more Sleek than you're used to
and this is not just a who is jigsaw so it which
gives a different approach whereas the other ones
are who is jigsaw for the saw X is it the tenth
one I Think Jesus because they stopped counting
after seven yeah so seven eight is jigsaw nine is
spiral and this is ten damn yeah oh this is the
tenth one yeah and to call it saw X this actually
feels confident and different usually by the time
you get to a tenth in a horror franchise you're
like oh let's do a subtitle they've got way off
the rails exactly it's a numeral 10 yeah you
have to be at least a little confident and I
mean you know it's also X which is the edgiest
letter of the alphabet you know that works for
a saw though of course yeah I've already gotten
pretentious about their like chapter [__] yeah
no it lends itself to the sleazy grindhouseness
that this whole torture genre partly hinges upon
even if these movies do care to have twists
and you know a sort of cop Thriller aesthetic
overall but that's not really here and we're
gonna see Amanda we're gonna see Amanda we're
gonna see the origins of Amanda that we were told
about now we get to see it play out a little more
because these two don't age at all or or because
they they look like they don't age at all but I'm
sure if I watched saw two and then I put this
trailer on it'd be like it definitely aged but
oh yeah when I mean it's growing up from being
like he's like 80 now yes what I'm just going
off of memory I'm like wow they haven't aged at
all you know yeah yeah but if I watched him back
to back sure that one definitely looks a lot older
Amanda certainly will look a bit older I feel like
she's she's younger than Toby Bell so that would
be more noticeable and now he's going after the
scam doctor here yeah yeah this is personal yeah
and taking away their anesthetic all the traps
seem like they'll have some kind of surgical
uh you know theme about them and the whole it's
not retribution it's an Awakening remember that's
where we got all the needles and two from yeah uh
still one of the most icky traps and he got some
anesthesia oxygen tank [__] and uh too as well
now we're gonna see the origins of two that's
right now we're gonna have some kind of crazy
was like this was actually happening in the same
house just in the Attic do you think we'll see Lee
wanell I don't know that would be cool that would
be cool I mean you know he's a sleazy photographer
but he didn't die he didn't die and they could
come back well no don't they find his corpse
like shriveled up I thought that would be Danny
Glover or was it Lee one out I think they find
his shriveled up corpse all right I think he
does die I guess I'm just not remembering but
you never know I mean we don't know how long he
was in there for I think we'll see Donnie Wilder
um uh probably not I don't know it's too bad
yeah I mean unless he's in Mexico maybe that's
where John Kramer meets him and is like
ah this guy needs a lesson maybe we'll
see Donnie Wahlberg's son yeah yeah he's one of
the nurses helping jigsaws let's see let's get
the same actor back too yeah to play himself
before it's a second movie be like uh yeah
he's in Mexico for some kind of Rejuvenation like
youthfulness treatment to keep him looking young
wow oh it's the 20th anniversary I saw I guess
it must be what is that 2004 or 2003 to 2023 sure
there's a comment here that says I'm Legit
actually legitimately crying I saw franchise
means the entire world to me so seeing this just
made my entire week really hey man crazy that saw
it is such a Negative film this is a very Bleak
world yeah and as much as I love them no it taught
me to appreciate life well that's the interesting
thing that's part of the interesting part of it is
that he does of all the moralistic killers when it
is actually John Kramer and not one of his deluded
uh you know his disciples he's got a good point
sometimes yeah I guess so that's what makes him
interesting and I hope they can maintain that
I mean I hope like the John Amanda stories are
often especially the John Kramer stories are like
the most rich part of Saw and oftentimes even in
the lowest lows of the saw franchise a good John
Kramer scene is a great scene so uh this was two
it was a two and a half minute trailer I thought
it was like four minutes I know I felt like a
really long trade yeah there's a lot in there and
there was a lot of like yeah epic like nostalgia
you've done it we've done our saw thing guys
leave us a thought in the comments are you
excited for saw X will you be there September
20 whatever opening night let us know your
favorite saw trap down below and we'll catch
you next time stay sexy rejack Nation [Music]